momento de hablar de economía en france
24 me acompaña en el estudio jorge
hurtado de nicaragua para el mundo jorge
buenas noches comenzamos hablando de
eeuu que prometió más fondos para
agilizar el tráfico en los puertos del
país de qué se trata así bueno santiago
el gobierno de joe biden anunció una
nueva ronda de ayudas federales
destinadas a modernizar los puertos
comerciales de eeuu
estos fondos buscan hacer el gran el
desarrollo de proyectos de
infraestructura portuaria para tratar de
aliviar la presión de la cadena de
suministro un problema que está
encareciendo los precios de varios
productos el puerto de savannah en
georgia recibirá una ayuda de 8 millones
de dólares en los próximos 30 días allí
se convertirán unos 5 terrenos en
depósitos para contenedores de de forma
que buscan ganar espacio en este
importante puerto de la costa sobre este
de eeuu pit british en el secretario del
transporte eeuu reconoció que hay una
demanda enorme en los puertos y que pese
al esfuerzo los puertos van a tener
problemas para seguir el ritmo el plan
de 1,2 millones de dólares contempla
unos 550 mil millones de dólares en
gasto nuevo y es la mayor inversión en
obras públicas eeuu en más de una década
el paquete aprobado incluye 17 mil
millones de dólares para mejoras en los
puertos costeros y terrestres jorgé
hoy chile y el senado de ese país han
sido noticia a lo largo de la jornada
qué pasó con la votación en ese país
sobre el cuarto retiro de pensiones
bueno por solamente un voto del senado
de ese país rechazó el polémico proyecto
de ley que busca autorizar a las
personas a realizar un cuarto retiro
anticipado del 10 por ciento de sus
fondos de pensiones desde la llegada de
la pandemia se han aprobado tres retiros
santiago del 10 por ciento de estos
fondos de pensiones lo que representa un
desembolso de más de 50 mil millones de
dólares para las administradoras de
fondos de pensiones que son conocidas
allí como las afp las afp mueven esos
recursos en el mercado financiero y hoy
se encuentran cuestionadas por la
ciudadanía por las bajas pensiones que
otorgan al final de la vida laboral
mientras las compañías gestoras obtienen
millonarios beneficios la mitad de los
contribuyentes chilenos reciben menos de
280 dólares al mes en pensiones según
datos de la fundación sol y eso está
generando que la mayoría de personas
quieran sacar su dinero de ahí el banco
central el anticipo que las
consecuencias del cuarto retiro pueden
tener efectos extremadamente graves
considerando que la cantidad de
circulante podría recalentar la economía
jorge el presidente de méxico andrés
manuel lópez obrador pidió acabar con la
pobreza aplicando más impuestos mi
pregunta es es esto novedoso bueno
propuso que las empresas más grandes del
mundo paguen nuevos tributos para crear
un fondo de ayuda para 750 millones de
personas que viven con menos de 2
dólares al día este fondo conformado por
la contribución voluntaria entre
comillas de magnates corporaciones
privadas y países sería de hasta 1000
millones de dólares anuales que deberían
llegar directamente a los beneficiarios
según amlo sin intermediarios a través
de una tarjeta o monedero electrónico
personalizado el presidente mexicano
nombró a su idea el plan mundial por la
fraternidad y el bienestar y recaudaría
un 4 por ciento de las personas más
ricas del mundo otro porcentaje según el
similar deberían pagar las mil empresas
más grandes y los países del g20
deberían destinar finalmente un 0,2 por
ciento de su producto interno bruto a
este fondo escuchemos un poco santiago
lo que declaró
nunca en la historia
de esta organización
se ha hecho algo realmente sustancial
en beneficio de los pobres
pero nunca es tarde
para hacer justicia
hoy es tiempo de actuar
contra la marginación atendiendo a las
causas y no solo las consecuencias a
tono con esta idea
en los próximos días la representación
de méxico propondrá a la asamblea
general de las naciones unidas un plan
mundial de fraternidad y bienestar
santiago lejano las soluciones globales
en méxico la tasa de inflación general
subió en octubre hasta el 6 24%
interanual su mayor nivel desde finales
de 2017 un fenómeno que no parece ser
transitorio y que afecta a los
energéticos y a los productores
agropecuarios pasemos ahora los
indicadores como las baldosas
principales bolsas del mundo mala wall
street cerró en rojo por el nerviosismo
de los datos sobre la inflación que se
esperan mañana las acciones europeas
retrocedieron desde sus máximos
históricos aunque los buenos resultados
empresariales y la esperanza de
recuperación limitaron las pérdidas y en
latinoamérica la bolsa mexicana cayó
luego de los malos datos de la inflación
que mencionaba antes muchas gracias
jorge por esta información del mundo de
la economía es todo por el momento siga
con nosotros
[Música]